what's crazy is like uh you know you're
used to
weed and alcohol and maybe cocaine like
not not but like hearing people do drugs
and then when you hear steve's like
drug breakdown you're like ketamine like
he's doing
horse i think it's probably safe to say
dad's never laying eyes on
the cannon i don't mean to say that but
like the norm of drugs you know
you could you've heard about cocaine i
was not into that no no
to be clear i'm not saying that you were
i'm sorry like i'm just saying like you
know
the you've heard about people doing it
in the movies but like
when you hear of steven's drug breakdown
dad dad
actually was with me brought me to the
rehab
to check me in and was sitting there in
the room
when they did their uh orientation
process to to
the the intake and they said okay
whatever your drug history what are your
drugs and dad
for the first time was hearing this list
of drugs and there was like [ __ ] he
never even heard of in his life what do
you remember what the drug breakdown
would have been like yeah like pcp
nitrous oxide ketamine you know like
video head cleaner like you know like
what the [ __ ] like
it was uh you know i mean you remember
that
vividly and you you're you're skipping
over what
i think was one of the toughest but one
of the best decisions in my life
you were having your final breakdown
right and you were sending you were
sending
emails to half the world talking about
how you were going to drive a motorbike
through your
apartment everybody knows that but what
they don't know is that when knoxville
organized my intervention
he reached out to you and he said mr
glover we're organizing an intervention
for
for your son and we really want you to
be there maybe need you to be there
and dad said i said no
and i thought really hard about it and
uh with hindsight
i was absolutely right steve and i had a
good relationship
then with one exception he wouldn't
allow me to talk about his personal life
and i know personally i mean about the
drinking and all that
i would not let you our relationship was
on my terms
yes because i didn't i didn't i wasn't
financially dependent on you like
i could have ostensibly just cut you out
of my life and been fighting yeah so i i
uh reasoned to think correctly that if i
had been there
you and i would have been in the center
of the room shouting at each other and
all your jackass buddies would have
been neutralized in dead silence
so i told knoxville and and dr drew
called me too and i said the same thing
to drew
i said yeah i'm going to come out
but i'm not going to come for the
intervention because
his jackass friends will do a much
better job without me
than they could possibly do with me yeah
and i think that
that was absolutely right and so then
they locked up the psych ward and then i
agreed in the psych where to go to the
rehab and you were with me at the rehab
absolutely and
and while we're checking into the rehab
dad says to me says you know
what like once once we get this behind
us you know like once you know you do
this and
and i said dad's never going to get
behind us you know ours or once we once
once we fix this dad this doesn't get
fixed i said dad i'm a drug addict i'm
an alcoholic that's never going to
change
it's going to be the rest of my life and
the fact that you were married to mom
for 25 years and you still don't
understand that is
[ __ ] you know like i i all of a
sudden like that was
day one of rehab and uh just because you
knew like
even staying sober it's just a lifelong
struggle i knew all about it and my
experience with my mom
yeah and i said dad i'd say dad i'm here
because i'm gonna take this really
seriously and uh and if you're gonna
uh if you're gonna not get in the way of
it i need you to i need you to sign up
to be a part of al-anon
and stuff so dad signs up for al-anon
i i went to regular al-anon meetings in
both london and florida
for at least a year yeah and then he dad
says to me says i don't get it he says
all these people in these meetings you
know like
they seem to be there for for their own
benefit and
i'm fine like i don't need any help i'm
just here to support you
and i say okay dad next time why don't
you just hand me a beer and a joint
no no no i i i i got one thing out of
al-anon that i'll never forget it was in
florida
and uh there was a woman who was
probably in her 60s and her husband
you know i'm not sure if he was in
recovery
or if he was still struggling but she
said something i'll never forget she
said
you know if you're living with somebody
who is mentally ill
you cannot avoid becoming mentally ill
yourself correct
and boy that resonated with me can i
just tell you how [ __ ] up my new tour
is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated
there's legal waivers all over the venue
because i'm actually worried about
getting sued
and i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly and it's all the stuff i wasn't
allowed to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats